foreign
[Music]
you guys it's tomes of Terror time once
again this is my book review series
so way back at the end of November of
2022
an author named Alan goldborn I guess is
how you pronounce his last name uh he
contacted me through email and he
actually offered to send me a couple of
his novels for review and of course you
know I accepted because you know free
books hey that's like one of my very
favorite things right uh now I actually
do regret that it's taken me this long
to get around to reading one of them but
as some of you might have noticed I
haven't been putting up as many tones of
Terror like recently because I got
really really behind on my reading
during holidays so you know this is a
failing that I've been trying to rectify
like now that the new year is kind of
upon us the holidays are over so I'm
really trying to get back into you know
my reading one book a week and putting
up a video about it kind of thing that I
was doing before so he sent me two books
but the one I decided to start with was
actually his second novel I didn't know
like which one was the first one which
one's second one I just like chose this
one because it sounded interesting so
this one is like the uh they came out in
2022
and it's a supernatural murder mystery
called the 666 murders uh he also sent
me a copy of his first novel which is
called uh from family can I I guess is
how you pronounce it uh so I'll
eventually get around to that one as
well so um the reason I picked this one
first is because you know I I Love
Murder Mysteries and the premise of this
one like I said sounded really
interesting so I just kind of uh dived
right into it so this author in case I
didn't mention it is British he's
actually from Essex so the story of the
666 murders uh takes place in 1966
mostly in and around London uh but some
events take place in France as well
so our main character is like a private
investigator named Randolph Landon
now at the start of the story
um he's been going through some [ __ ]
right
um him and his wife Thelma are they're
kind of doing a trial separation type of
thing like they haven't really fought or
anything like that but you know they
were having some problems they still
love each other and they're still on
good terms but uh the wife whose name is
Thelma she took the couple's
eight-year-old son Matthew like up to
Lincolnshire to stay with her parents
and really only comes down to visit
every few weeks they're still trying to
like sort some stuff out
um and Randolph really misses them like
misses his wife and son so he's kind of
like depressed about that also uh the
detective work has really been drying up
lately uh so much so that he's afraid
that he's not going to be able to afford
the rent on his kind of run down flat or
his run down office anymore uh you know
so he's kind of just worried that he's
gonna be unemployed and broke like
before too long he only has one case
pending at the beginning of the novel uh
this elderly woman has hired him to find
her absconded Chihuahua whose name is
Peanut uh but so far like Randolph
hasn't had any luck tracking down the
dog and he actually won't get the rest
of his fee until the dog turns up
whether the dog's alive or dead so he's
like kind of he's kind of at you know
he's like this is all he has going on so
he's really like upset that he hasn't
been able to find this damn dog so not
surprisingly uh Randolph has kind of
been drowning his Sorrows a little bit
at the local pub kind of lamenting the
shambles that his life has become uh he
has like some good friends like around
the place that he kind of knows and he's
actually built up some good will like
with the local police after he helped
them out like with a child kidnapping
case like at some point in the recent
past but you know all of these
connections that he has haven't really
seemed to have been all that much help
in scaring up more business and like I
said he's kind of worried that he's
going to be broke soon now the police by
the way uh have actually had their hands
pretty full for the last few weeks like
prior to the events of the novel uh
there have been two horribly horribly
gruesome murders like in this immediate
area both of the victims were found with
their hearts cut out and there were also
all of these weird items left at the
scenes so it appears that whoever did
these murders like was involved in the
occult because like the killings
definitely look like kind of ritualistic
sacrifices of some kind now Randolph has
been following the murder case in the
papers like as pretty much everybody has
um but he doesn't really have like a
direct stake in the investigation at
least not at first
um so because he's kind of like
depressed but he's also like very very
tenacious and he's unwilling to let down
a client he vows that he is going to
find that damn Chihuahua a peanut like
come hell or high water I mean it's his
only case he doesn't have anything else
going on and he's like well just there's
no excuse for me not devoting all my
time and resources to it because what
the [ __ ] else have I got to do right now
in the course of asking around about
peanut
he happens to cross paths with a Romani
woman named Miss albescue she's actually
camped in Hyde Park uh with the rest of
her clan with the rest of her group
whatever now when he when he first
approaches her she hasn't seen the dog
at first but Randolph like gives her his
information they kind of flirt a little
bit because she's real pretty and all
that
um and a bit later she actually does
spot peanut like scampering around and
so she immediately calls Randolph and
says hey I saw the dog like you might
want to come down here and like you know
see if you can get him
so Randolph Rush is down there and
chases the little [ __ ] but during the
course of pursuing the dog like through
it's kind of like the middle of the
night like through these kind of like
really dark and empty streets which is
like kind of creepy Randolph actually
Hears A man screaming and he follows it
because he's like hey maybe the guy
needs help obviously and he eventually
comes across another murder scene which
looks like it just happened like only a
few minutes before so the victim is
naked and he's like bent unnaturally
backwards um and he has his neck is
broken and his heart is removed and just
like in the first two murders because
it's the third one uh there are occult
things going on at the scene like
there's a pentagram on the floor and
there's black candles like at all the
points like burning with these really
weird like green Flames so Randolph of
course is uh pretty freaked out by this
as you would be
and he's also like really really guilty
that he didn't get there soon enough
like to save the man from this horrible
murder so the police are very
understanding like they do question him
obviously but they didn't like think
he's a suspect because they know him you
know what I mean he's been working with
them for a while
um and they actually kind of they don't
involve him in the case directly but
they do kind of give him like a little
bit of information about the
investigation and stuff
meanwhile uh peanut is recovered uh safe
and unharmed and he returns peanut to
the elderly lady who owned him and gets
the rest of his fee but now it seems uh
he's completely unemployed because that
peanut thing that was like the last case
that he had going on and now that's been
resolved so he's like well I guess I'm
unemployed now
so he actually goes to visit the Romani
woman Miss albescue to kind of like
thank her for helping him find the dog
and she offers him a free palm reading
now in the course of this though she
seems to have a vision of something
unpleasant like in his future and
basically just she doesn't really know
exactly what it is it's just like a bad
feeling that she has so she basically
says to Randolph like be careful just be
on guard
um and beware of like a certain symbol
like she can't really articulate what it
is that she sees
um but she knows that there's probably
something bad and he just needs to like
watch his back so Randolph not gonna lie
is a little bit
I guess annoyed by how vague her
predictions are and he's also like real
disheartened by you know the lack of
work obviously so Randolph is kind of
bummed he heads back to his office but
as luck would have it a new client
arrives just in the nick of time
and this new client is a very beautiful
and very sophisticated woman named
Claret Andrews and she wishes to engage
Randolph's services
she believes that her husband Timothy
who is this very very wealthy owner of
like a chain of luxury hotels has been
cheating on her and she's willing to pay
Randolph quite a princely Psalm to
follow Timothy around and see what he's
up to because he's been acting kind of
suspicious so Randolph is pretty
grateful for this uh he does feel a
little bit uncomfortable with like how
much the woman is paying him but she
also has a business and she's also quite
wealthy in her own right and doesn't
really seem to mind
now in the course of tailing her husband
Timothy Andrews around England and
France because I guess like they have a
villa there and things like that
Randolph actually ends up becoming
involved in something that is a lot
bigger and a lot more Sinister than just
like a little piddling extramarital
affair
turns out in fact that Timothy is not
cheating on his wife at all actually he
quite adores his wife and would never do
such a thing but what he has been doing
and didn't really want to involve her in
it is that he's been low-key
investigating the very mysterious
disappearance of I guess like his
ex-wife or his ex-girlfriend who he's
not like um sleeping with or anything
like that but he is like a good friend
of hers although they hadn't hadn't kind
of spoken for a long time but she like
disappeared and he was worried about her
because it was like unlike her so um her
name is Natalie Connors so that's what
he's been doing like going back and
forth to France and stuff like that and
this other woman he's been seen with is
like actually Natalie's assistant so
he's been trying to find her and didn't
really want to tell his wife because he
might he thought she might think it was
weird or whatever now Natalie Connors
the woman that disappeared as an
archaeologist and she had recently
discovered this very bizarre
find like in this sort of like cave or
this underground kind of thing in France
like with some skeletons and like some
weird stuff like that so over the course
of the novel then uh the seemingly
unrelated threads of The archaeologist's
Disappearance in France and all of these
grisly like ritualistic murders taking
place in London kind of slowly start to
come together and uh poor Randolph you
know since he got sucked into this whole
thing being uh you know because
eventually he gets uh hired by Timothy
like to help him look for the
archaeologist he kind of finds himself
caught in the middle of this
Supernatural [ __ ] storm I guess of like
epic proportions and probably I'm gonna
say kind of like a Biblical proportions
too a little bit so I actually enjoyed
this book uh quite a bit it was pretty
good uh I love detective stories and
this one kind of had a little bit of a
Noir vibe to it that I found really
appealing it's the way it was kind of
set up reminded me a little bit of maybe
like Chinatown where it was just kind of
like oh you're you know it's a pi and
they're investigating what they think is
initially like an affair but then it
turns out to be something I mean
obviously I know Chinatown didn't have
Satanism and stuff like that in it but
it's kind of the same thing where you
just get sucked in this thing and you
think it's one thing but it turns out to
be this big complicated other thing so
it kind of like um came across a little
bit like that
um I also really liked the juxtaposition
of this kind of like hard-boiled
investigator meeting like essentially
satanic forces or kind of like a
witchcraft type of thing it's kind of I
guess it's kind of along the same lines
as maybe something like the omen or the
Believers the that kind of reminded me
the Believers or like the first power or
something like that if you remember that
movie with Lou Diamond Phillips where
it's just kind of like a realistic
Pi type story like investigative type
story but then also with like
Supernatural or like witchcraft or
occult like elements to it so it's kind
of like that now the novel is quite long
uh clocks in at about 500 pages but I
actually finished it in probably just a
few hours I think it's like over two
days you know what I mean like you know
two out two or three hours here two or
three hours there so it didn't really
take me all that long to read it because
even though it seemed like at first it
seemed like there was a lot of
just disparate elements that seemed like
they didn't have anything to do with one
another like slowly everything kind of
started to come together a little bit so
and I was kind of curious as to how
everything was going to connect to each
other now that said I did have a few
minor nitpicks with it
I will say that while the writing was
refreshingly almost completely free of
grammatical errors which you guys know
what a big deal that is for me I was
like woo Hallelujah uh you know what I
mean it was very the tone of it was very
I'm gonna call it like expositional you
know what I mean particularly in regards
to the dialogue like there were passages
where one character would give kind of
like this long expository monologue to
like some other characters and while
this was all necessary information that
you know had to be imparted to the
reader I kind of wish that there had
been like maybe a more elegant way of
conveying the information you know what
I mean rather than having somebody like
monologue because at times it sounded
like expositional like I said it didn't
sound like a natural way of talking like
it didn't sound like somebody talking
naturally it sounded like somebody like
expositing you know what I mean so it
just kind of sounded like that because
of that I think at times like the
dialogue of all the different characters
kind of tended to sound the same because
they were just kind of giving a rundown
of information that the reader needed to
know so it was kind of at times
difficult to tell who was talking
because the characters didn't really
have their own distinct voices they were
just basically you got less the
impression that they were just like
talking like naturally than they were
just like here's all this information
you need to know like I said very
expository
um the bad guy too seemed a little bit
like a bond Villain Like toward the end
he didn't really talk through most of
the uh of the book but then like at the
end he'd like starts talking like a
[ __ ]
um and he was like describing exactly
what he's gonna do and kind of like
gloating over it and things but probably
he should have just done what he was
going to do without explaining it which
you know give the good guys time to [ __ ]
him up like I said it was kind of like a
bond villain type situation that's kind
of what it reminded me of a little bit
there were also kind of like a lot of
just kind of small talk interactions and
scenes with Randolph just kind of going
about his day and like talking to
various people that he knew like the
newspaper guy like the bartender the man
who cleaned his office building he was a
friend of his that didn't really end up
factoring into the plot
in any way probably really didn't need
to be included it did give some kind of
like I guess context to this not really
context but just to like a little bit of
character to the story I guess like you
got to know him a little bit better but
I don't know if a lot of that stuff
needed to be in there really because it
didn't really seem to come to anything
some of the conversations too I felt
like were slightly repetitive like
something would happen and then a scene
or two later Randolph would be telling
someone else what happened when it we
had already read about it or the same
thing happened too sometimes it's like
oh well we got this information and then
like it would be repeated a couple times
like well different characters were
telling it to different people you know
what I mean when that probably didn't
need to be in there either and also I
think there were actually a couple of
maybe anachronisms that I noticed like
the story was like I said was set in
1966 and the police were very freely
using the term serial killer which as
far as I know didn't really come into
common usage until the 70s like maybe
around 1974 something like that and in
this story they were even saying oh it's
three victims now now it's a serial
killer and I don't know if anybody in
1966 would have phrased it that way now
the phrase serial murderer I think had
been an occasional use like since maybe
about the 1930s
um I'm not saying that nobody had ever
used the term serial killer like in 1966
for example but I just don't think it
was a common uh you know it in the way
that people use it nowadays I don't
think it was that common
um some of the characters also I kind of
felt like used other turns of phrase
which sounded a little bit too modern to
my ears but this might have been just a
case of like you know British English
versus American English so I'm not
entirely sure I'm not all that familiar
with British English from the 60s so I
don't know like if some of the phrases
were you know in common usage back then
or whatever so I'm not going to get like
all that upset about it so overall like
I said this was actually pretty good it
was a pretty uh intriguing read and a
pretty fun uh detective story with kind
of an undercurrent of you know the
occult or black magic witchcraft craft
stuff like that so if that sounds like
your cup of tea then uh you know then
give it a shot and let me know what you
think about it uh as I said I got uh
copies from the author himself but I
believe if you have Kindle unlimited um
I think at least this book you can read
it for free on there so if it sounds
interesting go check it out and tell me
what you think about it in the comments
and that will do it for this tomes of
Terror I'll see you guys again on the
next one bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]